we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in oh
yeah i'm just calling to suggest
something not really ask a question
alright
i just wanted to suggest that you read a
little bit more marks when installing
and just anything related to those
people i think it'd be good for you
don't necessarily change your core
beliefs but like i don't know you just
seem too liberal at all you know what I
don't get if I seem too liberal why
would I read Marx Stalin and Lenin like
I don't I'm just not sure it's it's an
interesting call and I've read I've read
Marx I've not read anything by Stalin or
Lenin but I'm just not understand I
understand if I seem too liberal I
should read those but not to change my
views I don't know is the idea that if
you go so far to the left that you're no
longer liberal or you become more
authoritarian and that's not liberal is
that the idea
like it'll scare me out of the left or
something like that I don't know yeah
anyway I'm open to reading all sorts of
stuff I always have like ten books ready
and waiting for me so it would take me a
little while I think to be able to get
two more marks or some Stalin or Lenin
but thank you for the idea always always
up for reading suggestions on the bonus
show today Donald Trump has commuted the
sentence of Alice Marie Johnson we will
talk about that there's a new study from
the US Army which claims to know the
best time of the day to drink coffee for
Pat it's all day yes all day and Mitch
McConnell has canceled most of the
August recess for the Senate Sean
Hannity almost had an orgasm as a result
of that he was on Twitter just saying
it's the best thing almost had breasts
it's the best thing because he's gonna
cancel the break to push Trump's agenda
forward or some kind of harebrained
explanation anyway we will talk about
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show how do you access the bonus
show two ways number one join pakman.com
become a member at join Pakman
number two become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show sign
up today we'll speak to you on the bonus
show